Aneen, good morning, everyone.
First and foremost,
I just want to acknowledge and welcome everyone here today
to this historic meeting for Manitoba
and for our people. I thought that it was really important
and our team thought that it was really important
to have our young ones starters off in a good way
because what we're discussing today
and what we're doing today is for our young ones
and for those next generations.
This
meeting signals a pivotal shift
towards giving the due respect to First Nations leadership
as governments and towards honoring indigenous laws for our children
and our families.
But the reality is
that our people have always known how to take care of our children,
always. So
the commitment that we're making is that
there's not gonna be any barriers
or not gonna be any foot dragging,
there's not gonna be,
let me go talk to the bureaucracy or what have you.
When you step up to say we're assuming child welfare,
you have a minister, you have a provincial government
that is going to move quickly and make sure that Anishinaabe kids,
Anishinaabe kids, Dakota kids,
Denay kids, Cree kids can grow up in Anishinaabe,
Anishinaabe, the quota,
then a and Cree families. Let's govern in such a way
that we don't have to come back here in 20 years
and apologize to this generation of children.
We finally have a government in Manitoba that we can work with.
I think you could all agree.
With that, like this thing that we signed here today,
this is gonna take teamwork.
We have a lot of work to do.
But this is literally the first time in our history in this province
that we have the means of getting this done.
This is literally the first time.
And so my solemn promise to everybody is that I am dedicated to that.
My door is always open, my phone is always on,
and I will always make myself available to everyone
because at the end of the day,
the only thing that matters,
not our titles, not how long we've been in these roles,
the only thing that matters is our children. That's all that matters.